welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Monday June 5th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
delivering vaccines in many countries
around the world can be tricky things
like insufficient Cold Storage can stand
in the way of eradicating diseases like
measles which caused 128
000 deaths in 2021 according to the
World Health Organization but technology
that delivers these vaccinations in
patches could fix that our reporter
Brian Gormley who covers venture capital
and health care for the wsj pro team
will join us to explain this Tech and
the startups making it but first Call of
Duty is arguably one of the most
successful video game franchises ever
and it's at the center of the debate
over whether Microsoft should be allowed
to buy Call of Duty's owner Activision
Blizzard for 75 billion dollars
Regulators worry the deal could give
Microsoft an unfair Edge in the video
gaming industry the UK is competition
and markets Authority mentioned Call of
Duty 41 times in its decision to reject
the deal in April the U.S Federal Trade
Commission cited the game 18 times in
its complaint to quash the acquisition
and even though the European Union
approved the tie up last month that came
only after Microsoft pledged to allow
competitors to stream Call of Duty and
other Activision games over the cloud
our Tech reporter Sarah needleman is
with me to discuss what makes this
gaming franchise so important so Sarah
for people who haven't played Call of
Duty the players are set in a war
scenario but can you tell us how long
the game has been around for and just
what makes it so popular this franchise
is two decades old and what's made it
popular is a combination of factors for
one when it came out that was just when
online multiplayer gaming was starting
to come into Vogue so it really came at
the right time and there weren't as many
other Shooters back then as there are
today and compared to the other shooters
that were available back then Call of
Duty really had Superior graphics and
it's one of those games that's easy to
learn but hard to master people really
gravitated toward it quite quickly and
because it had that early mover
Advantage you could say it continued to
snowball over time and Activision
Blizzard invests a large amount of money
into the game the company doesn't say
exactly how much but analyst estimates
it's in the hundreds of millions of
dollars that they put every year into
this franchise okay so it is very
popular but it's still just one
franchise so while your Regulators so
fixated on it Regulators are concerned
that Microsoft off could potentially
make Call of Duty exclusive to its own
cloud gaming platform and locking out
others from being able to provide it to
players and so the thinking is that
consumers would gravitate towards
Microsoft's cloud gaming Service uh with
cloud gaming it's pretty new but what
the technology does is allow people to
play video games from just about any
internet connected device with a screen
so essentially Smart TVs mobile phones
laptops you don't have to punk down
hundreds of dollars on a video game
console like the Xbox or Playstation nor
do you have to spend a lot of money on a
gaming PC what if Microsoft and
Activision said about these concerns the
companies have said that the deal won't
hurt competition and that if they've
committed to licensing Call of Duty
games to Rivals and to enabling people
to stream current and future Activision
titles including Call of Duty through
the cloud gaming platform of their
choice alright that was our Tech
reporter Sarah needleman
imagine a world where the next time you
need to get a vaccination a doctor
doesn't have to take out a big needle
instead they could just pop a patch on
your arm a number of Biotech startups
are working to create that future and
while it could help eradicate diseases
in places where vaccinations are hard to
deliver investors are betting on
potential closer to home with us now to
discuss this is Brian Gormley who covers
venture capital and health care for the
wsj pro team let's talk a little bit
about this vaccination patch how does
the technology work these are patches
that contain what they call Micro
needles and the needles penetrate just
under the skin and they release the
vaccine or different types of microneal
patches that various types of companies
are developing but the basic concept is
the same and they say they do so with
little or no pain can you tell us a
little bit about why
in wealthy Nations such as the United
States there's not a problem of
maintaining Refrigeration of vaccines
from the time they are distributed right
up until the time they are injected but
in certain parts of the world such as
areas of sub-Saharan Africa maintaining
a proper cold chain of distribution all
the way up the time of injection is can
be challenging when there is limited
Refrigeration in electricity and the
vaccines that are formulated for
delivery on the micro needle patches are
stable at higher temperatures than the
conventional vaccine that is injected
into the arm where does this Tech
technology stand at the moment the
concept of microneedle patches has been
in existence for probably about 20 years
or so but the current patches that are
being tested now are fairly early stage
clinical trials and they will need
larger phase clinical studies to
validate their effectiveness before they
are become more routinely used are
specific challenges then of delivering
vaccinations via patch as opposed to
delivering them the traditional way the
early clinical trials show that at least
for companies including Micron
biomedical which is a startup in Atlanta
that the vaccination by the patch
triggers a similar immune response as a
traditional vaccine delivered by
injection however that has to be
validated in larger clinical trials to
see if that benefit holds up when it's
used more widely across a greater number
of patients can you us a little bit more
about these startups that are developing
the vaccination patches two of the
companies I was focusing on are Micron
biomedical and vaxis both are applying
their microneedle patch technology both
to measles rubella vaccines that can be
used in lower low and middle income
countries but also to other types of
drugs and vaccines that could be applied
in the United States and other high
income countries seasonal influenza is
one covid-19 vaccines are another
possibility
invest
ORS see the work that these companies
are doing for measles and rubella as a
validation of the technology and an
opportunity to gain more experience
using it but from the pure investment
side of the story the real payoff for
them is going to be if these companies
are successful in delivering vaccines in
the United States and other high income
countries that's where the big payoff is
going to be for them if it occurs are
there different things that investors
are taking into consideration when
they're putting money into these
biomedical startups ones that have to
deal with regulatory approval and
People's Health as opposed to maybe you
know a new social media Venture
absolutely they have to factor in a wide
range of technical logistical markets
and medical issues before making an
investment in these companies they have
to be convinced that these technologies
will be able to deliver vaccines as
effectively as a needle dose for example
they have to be convinced that there is
a payoff in the end enough demand from
patients and Healthcare Providers
vaccine makers drug companies for this
technology so it's quite a lot of
analysis that goes into making an
investment in companies that have this
much technical development ahead of them
and also medical scientific risk all
right that's wsj reporter Brian Gormley
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]